au lycée jean vilar à plaisir c'est
leçon de littérature cet après midi pour
les élèves
hugo boris écrivain raconte aux lycéens
son rapport à l'écriture
son parcours personnel et donne quelques
conseils pour trouver de l'inspiration
et développer sa créativité
j'ai trouvé très intéressant le fait il
explique les différentes raisons qui
l'ont poussé à écrire
et là il nous a vraiment expliquer dans
les détails et oui j'ai trouvé très j'ai
trouvé ça très très intéressant ça m'a
beaucoup plus et je crois c'est le
moment qui m'a le plus intéressé c'est l
interaction entre l'auteur et nous il
nous donnait ses procédés d'écriture ça
j'ai bien aimé parce que comment
l'écriture c'est un monde qui
m'intéresse pendant un après-midi les
romans de littérature classique sont
restés dans les sacs
une rencontre qui permet de découvrir
des écrivains en dehors du programme
scolaire
moi j'ai abordé cette leçon en me disant
que c'était l'occasion de 2,2 de parler
de littérature de l'intérieur sait
vraiment comment je j'élabore je
construis un livre une action proposé
par la région ile de france et par les
professeurs du lycée une fois par an un
écrivain vient parler de son actualité
aux lycéens
laurent souchon professeur de lettres à
proposer cette rencontre avec hugo boris
c'est une vraie rencontre vivante
d'abord ils rencontrent les auteurs dans
leur singularité et puis aussi découvre
le processus de création les oeuvres
sont donc portés par le contemporain
elle reflète les problèmes de notre
société
une leçon de littérature qui a redonné
envie de lire et d'écrire à de futurs
écrivains en herbe la prochaine leçon de
littérature se déroulera le 19 mars à
saint germain en laye